hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to 60 seconds in the
last episode I did horribly and
apparently the music's done now so I'm
going to be talking to you guys in
silence boy this isn't awkward at all
huh umm okay
so my vision is a live game alright so
in the last episode I did terribly
because I didn't even realize and I
should have realised this I wasn't
supposed to feed my family that much I
was practically wasting all of my money
to try to get them involved and I
already see the radio over there I know
it's the radio but I'm gonna grab Go Go
Go Go Go Go I'm ready oh oh here we go I
know I know I know dump it and dump it
in coming in coming in coming in dumb
dumb dumb dumb dumb but I see the radio
right that is not the radio that is a
briefcase why do I care about that
that's not the radio Oh Teddy sprinkles
I'm not gonna make it in time okay gotta
grab the whites gotta grab the wife
gotta grab the wife gotta grab the wife
gotta grab a bottle of water got to grab
another bottle of water if I could just
hurry up that'd be great oh is that the
radio there that looks like a radio okay
so we're going good I know where that is
I'm gonna make an exam no honey that's
not the radio oh is the radio over here
where it always is is it always in
disables it's always in the goddamn same
place isn't it oh I got to get my kid
where are you little Timmy little Tim
Billy can't get a lock that oh I don't
have any left oh I can make it one more
time one more trip out one more trip out
water Trevor get some water okay I get
some water
hmm ed get good water good okay go go go
perfect that's enough Oh fire axe God
thumbs up thumbs up in yes get it oh
hell yeah that was a great start okay so
my problem in the last episode was that
I didn't ration it well enough and
you're supposed to ration things because
people can live for a few days without
stuff so if you have enough at least in
the beginning you're gonna be okay in
rationing everything out just fine so I
have bullets but not a gun and that's a
problem because my family is already
very mad at me all of us made it but we
found extra bullets ah so in the last
episode did I send Mary Jane out there
with a gun and no bullets because that
was probably good so lucky we took that
suitcase
okay so
the suitcase had extra stuff in it so
we're fine we're all under 4 cent fine
we're gonna do just fine we even have a
large jug of water which is wonderful so
we always thought life could be much
better that was before we got nuked now
we think life could be much better in a
way he not that much has changed ok so
in this one and also I had a very
strange encounter I was out in Glendale
the other day and a fan came up to me
and said that they saw this video and
that's totally fine I was really I was
really appreciative that but they told
me that it's very important if I play it
again that I say yes to every single
scenario and I don't know why that would
be they might just be messing with me
but I'm gonna take their advice so Jared
if I see you again and this is wrong
I'm gonna punch in the gut so that's
just a promise for you alright living in
the past is not wise in our current
situation we need to think of today and
tomorrow I really hope the name was
Jared it was something with a J now I'm
questioning things sorry anyway
mary-jane says she's fine and doesn't
need anything ok so everyone's fine
alright
don't need no one needs anything
everyone's fine ok so but we do need to
hassle up for it
expedition so mary-jane is more than
ready and someone said that I didn't
need to send out Ted unless it was an
absolute emergency because Ted could die
out there and if Ted dies the whole game
goes to crap ok we had planned to go to
Niagara Falls and see those beautiful
waterfalls we never expected to get a
waterfall in our very own shelter right
now it seems that a half a dozen pipes
bursting all that water is pouring right
into our bunker we need to save our
supplies weld all the radio there's
nothing else to save and actually that's
good that there's so much water can we
bottle some of it please please tell us
please tell me we did some the radio was
rescued first before any of the filthy
liquid got into its case it wasn't long
before most of the water disappeared but
the damage had done was enough to upset
us cleaning and fixing this mess would
take days and what's that smell
oh so it's bad water ok so we got
everything so everyone is going to get
water cuz you don't need soup yet
everyone's getting water but they don't
need soup yet and then I'm gonna send oh
they don't have a gas mask we don't have
any gas masks oh wow what's worse could
happen wife of mine you have fun out
there with a fire axe cuz what else
could happen probably a lot okay this is
probably a bad mood move but she's in a
bad mood and that means that she's gonna
come back with a lot of supplies a lot
of hope for our survival role girl okay
Mary Jane isn't worried everyone's okay
Dolores took the equipment and she's
gonna be fine uh what did it say as far
as food okay everyone seems to be food
good so we should last a few more days
had spear ammunition but now it's gone
we don't know how or when it must have
been this place we need to find it in
soon
okay good am I gonna trade what do you
mean it was right there in the cabinet
were you dumb well the answer is
probably everyone here is very very very
dumb okay the first thing we found was a
forgotten deck of cards Delores used it
for solitaire back in the day we can now
play semi solitaire oh okay uh Mary Jane
isn't feeling is feeling safe who
wouldn't in this coffin sighs shelter
okay so that do they still not need food
that's actually shocking if they don't
but everyone seemed to be fine it hey I
guess that's good then maybe they're all
gonna die but soon I I can only assume
that I'm the best dad in the world and
my kids love me because I'm haven't fed
them any food in six days which is
wonderful right okay I relocation is
probably something we'll be able to
discuss after we get out here died could
use a little food getting something to
drink okay so they're both very hungry
okay so maybe it's like a clue as to
what I can get make I'm trying to be the
best dad that I can here and give my
kids only the bare minimum needed to
survive I mean dad applier here is
really really caring about his family
and I'm gonna get this okay I'm
gonna go sweep the board and say
everyone gets a share because no that
ain't right
Ted needs water Timmy needs food and
water okay so they need food and water
but I only need water so I'm being the
self-sacrificing dad that I am and I'm
caring for everybody it's really weird
when you get the feeling that
something's watching you our shelter is
tiny but this has been bugging us for
awhile we checked all the closets and
Noah's hiding there what is there
something alive down here besides us
maybe a rodent and so we need to show
that we're the dominant species in this
little paradise of ours oh yeah that's
an intelligent way to go about your
survival in the trap little shelter that
you're in is they're gonna attack us
oh no oh god someone shout out another
can of soup oh boy as we were running
around looking for something to smash
the furry rodent with it just
disappeared so did one of our food kids
god damn it wasn't the Hecky hack how is
that possible I lost an entire can of
soup Mandalore is better coming back
with something good
there isn't anything bothering dire
circumstances Timmy is very brave Ted
stomach is rumbling okay so Ted gets
soup since we're all on soup how can
have we're not alone there's a huge
hairy bunny Beast it seems to be hiding
in the pipes it's been poking its head
out Oh God we can't let it be in here
when we slew what do you mean I let
Delores take the axe oh no oh no oh no
are we gonna get murdered by a giant
bunny I don't know what to do about that
the handbook didn't prepare me for this
situation oh boy that beast of a rodent
wanted one in stole our food can or no
can at least we have each other right
what are you talking about this is
horrible
I've lost two cans of food because I
said Delores with the axe this is not my
fault if I don't survive this it's not
my fault this is [ __ ] this [ __ ]
oh no everyone's fine Oh
we have so much water but not enough
anything else stuff surviving in these
conditions let's hope this will be over
soon
or else we might end up dead in some
wasteland ditch that's not something
we're looking forward to no it's not
because we got a giant rabbit bunny in
our shelter with us and I can't
did you guys hear that I can't name them
fluffernutter because that just wouldn't
be appropriate in the situation I may be
going Madame Dolores is not coming back
is she it's easy to feel a bit down when
living underground like this no sunshine
no sky we need to get rid of that
pessimism try to bring some cheerfulness
into our lives Mary Jane woof
everyone thirsty good thing we got
plenty of water I know for a fact we got
a lot of that and I'm pretty sure
Dolores has just gone forever good news
the government just announced they'll be
dropping crates filled with supplies in
our area we should head out and get
those crates as soon as possible
grabbing some protection gear might not
be a bad idea well we don't have that
either I grabbed all the booze Oh
Dolores Oh Dolores Dolores Dolores Wow
it was too dangerous to go out there
without any protection so we decided to
stay indoors and listen to the radio the
static is so relaxing we were glad to
see Dolores come back safely from the
wasteland but did she bring anything
when a man is desperate enough any place
is gonna look to forget food and water
our expedition was coming home with
nothing to show for all the searching
but they stumbled across trash cans full
in our neighborhood one man's trash is
another man's treasure
okay good we even got a gas mask oh oh
this is looking good oh this is good Oh
Dolores hasn't eaten for a while and
she's really tired and she's sick but
that's fine
cuz she's the only one that needs food
and water and I'm gonna give her a
medkit we're gonna do oh thank you wife
oh alright Mary Jane you're up maybe I
should give you some food today maybe
that was the problem okay Mary Jane you
get food and you're going out you're
going out and you're gonna get them
you're gonna be strong
no I forgot to give you a gas mask [ __ ]
oh you're back wait what the hell wait
did I do something around when we
answered the phone we could clearly hear
a gasp of relief from the caller they
introduced themselves the survivors from
a near dive town of Valley Hill Hill
Valley we had started exchanging
information when the call cut short
something that must have gone wrong in
their side we hope they will get back to
us okay nothing made us happier than the
sight of mary-jane returning this
shelter from the service mary-jane seems
fine okay wait that doesn't make any
sense the horse hasn't eaten for a while
yes she did she just ate yesterday it's
cured from her illness okay more food
for Dolores jeez the hog but everyone
else is okay on everything else god damn
it god damn it we might be in safe
inside these walls but there are other
problems to consider none of us can
sleep properly oh we don't have enough
for that we'll just all be very tired oh
no Mary Jane won't be able to go out
[ __ ] okay Mary Jane my champion is not
gonna be able to go out okay Timmy can't
go out cuz he's okay Timmy needs far too
long
you can't leave Timmy without water for
too long okay Timmy needs food and water
and then Delores has not eaten for all
what are you talking about she ate
yesterday dang it all right Timmy needs
food and water and I guess Delores needs
food again this is horrible this is
going terribly
Timmy you're going out and you're going
out with the gas mask all right good
luck buddy
good luck champ you're gonna get him
you're gonna do good you're gonna do
good good things to good people and
you're gonna be great when you do the
good thing that you do we're gonna die
horribly oh man Delores Jesus stop being
so hungry all right so everyone needs
water
yeah everyone needs water holy crap this
bad we can't keep sitting on our
backsides here in this tiny little
bunker we can start thinking about
getting away from as far as possible
from this radioactive wasteland who
would have thought the Reds would ruin
such a lovely neighborhood we could do
it on her own escaping part not the
ruining part of course however there it
might be something okay let's call out
cuz otherwise we are doomed to death due
to horrible difficulty all right
we knew it the government has not fallen
than they're coming to save us they
didn't give exact dates on the radio
transmission but we're sure they won't
keep us waiting long they said they will
be in touch in a few days and told us to
await further instructions
cool I think mary-jane is quite hungry
we don't have any food oh and Dolores is
finally doing fine we don't have any
food left guys you gotta you gotta go
you maniacs you blew it up Oh No
all right anyway damn it he's getting
dicey was getting really dicey all he's
getting really bad I mean Mary Jane
looks like she could survive for a while
without food that's mean to say but in a
survival situation every bit counts
let's see why it seems okay the problem
is simple if we don't wash ourselves
we'll get sick seriously sick it smells
really bad down here doesn't seem like
it'll get any better over the next
couple days how about we do something
about to fix it what are we gonna shoot
the dirt off each other what are we
gonna do with bullets we're just gonna
scrape him up on our body and hope we
get clean and they don't explode what
kind of logic is that to use the gun
power to burn all the dirt off of us
this is completely illogical but I'm
loving it and I'm with it TMA Oh Timmy
looks bad
Timmy looks gaunt and terrible and he
didn't find any food damn it dirty or
not it's the smell that's the biggest
issue how do we deal with it we've got
some ammo so why not use the Gunpowder
to kill the smell oh wow
Oh seemed like the Creech what we were
not alone outside the shelter at first
it seemed like the creature stalking us
was about to get a tasty dinner to our
relief it turned out to be a friendly
monkey it joined our expedition at one
point during our expedition the monkey
started making weird sounds digging in
front of us with a stick and we got a
water bottle and we damaged our gas mask
ah-ha-ha-ha-ha water for everybody
Oh No why couldn't you find food why
didn't I get more food why did I get so
many things and not enough food all
right
Dolores has not been very talkative
lately should we chat with her and find
out what's wrong
according to Jarrod I think that was the
name I should say yes so let's talk to
Dolores
because talking to our family members is
what we should do as it togetherness
team oh okay
Richie fording food she better not have
been hoarding food talking to Dolores
helped resolve some of her issues and
doubts she feels better now okay so it
really is just fun family family time
oh no if you do know I'm dead oh no oh
no Mary Jane go run run as far as you
can run she could take the suitcase and
then maybe haul back some more food for
herself when she's alive but instead
we're all gonna be dead oh god he's not
dead yet but he looks dead Mary Jane
went outside whoo water for everybody
how do we have any med kit left we don't
have any med kit left that's the point
it's been a while we don't know much
about what's happening on the surface
okay so we got a radio well we're gonna
die dad's dead dad's gonna die
that said Ted's dead flies Timmy what
are you doing
Timmy stop you haven't gone that crazy
why did you rip open your teddy bear and
also where did you get a teddy bear from
Delores take care of your son and love
your husband for goddamn sake he may be
a skeleton but he's still a man that
needs love oh we're all dead we're so
dead whoa whoa to see oh man uh we were
able to get a week this signal and tap
in
the fallout outside is mostly Ghana
should be much safer to travel on the
surface now Timmy was driven crazy the
loris has not eaten for a while well
great
good Timmy's crazy we've been wondering
what happened to uncle Brian it should
have been far from where the bombs fell
but no one knows for sure it would be
great to find out he always looked on
the bright side of life Oh Brian life
that's funny
always look on the bright side Tim he's
dead oh [ __ ] damn II ran away
hunger drum Timmy insane when he
realized we won't be able to provide for
him he snuck out and never returned
great so we're left with no photos milk
news and no happy thoughts the world is
too cruel Delores would like something
to eat and in fact the Loras is left
alone with the skeletal remains of her
husband and she doesn't look too
perturbed about it oh wow how about some
water you've earned it lady you've
earned it
we've been busy since we got to the
shelter but there's still much to be
done like trimming the shrubbery in our
yard yeah that's important right now
Oh Mary JWoww Mary Jane have you gone
insane
Dolores are you okay please tell me that
your bones are just constricting for
malnutrition and you're not going cray
cray because I'm pretty sure Mary Jane
Oh
and they neither of them found food
that's that's great that's great that's
great Oh yep but two bottles of water
that's good ha ha ha oh man Mary Jane's
diet could use a little food
Mary Jane contracted an illness Mary
Jane went nuts Mary Jane was pretty
fatigued Mary Jane is really tired
Delores barely has any strength left he
doesn't need something tonight she will
not last till morning Delores is sanity
is questionable how about some water oh
my god oh no one can go outside what do
you mean mean someone go outside it's
impossible oh well they're still alive
for another day oh man we needed to go
outside
we were supposed to go outside because
we needed to be in contact with people
oh no oh no dancing cockroach but one
nearly as big as a cat bad news is
they're huge and will probably attacks
when they get the chance I don't know if
that's a problem we got giant mutant
bunnies Oh No there we go that's oh my
god
Oh Doris Oh Horace oh my god oh that's
amazing oh that's amazing
poor Delores oh no oh this gone horribly
wrong all right oh my that thing is huge
and there goes another one roaches
everywhere we're doomed we already feel
dirty and they ate Delores great okay
good lasted 23 days though so that's
arguably better than we did last time
all right I perished I'm embarrassed I'm
embarrassed for me I'm embarrassed for
everyone but mostly me so anyway that is
all for this episode of 60 seconds in
the next one I Will Survive I Will
Survive I promise I know what I need to
get I need to get less stuff and more
food and water because oddly enough
that's important for surviving in the
environment so we'll get there in a
second so thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know how I did in
the comments below I know I did bad but
better than last time and that's all
that matters here it is I love -
surviving the apocalypse it is really
fun for me and my family when we're
alive we're really happy we're all dead
so we're kind of sad anyway thank you
everyone everybody for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
Oh oh god I'm so bad in games